So we went with one trainee at a time...
...and it just means that we can kind of focus on their individual needs.
So, they start when they come on board with myself...
...and then slowly over time as they build up their confidence,...
...into the final endpoint of transitioning them...
...onto whatever it is they want to do afterwards.
Obviously, I had nowhere to stay.
I had no one in my life, no structure...
...and I was very confused, very hurt and I had no confidence.
The training here not only showed me how to make coffee,...
...but it also showed me how to deal with people,...
...and how to kind of get my own confidence back,...
...how to put myself back in life as it were.
Through our Pay It Forward wall,...
...we've given away over 7,000 coffees and 5,000 meals, which is impact...
...that we're super proud of so far.
I think, for me, the thing was that people are intrinsically good...
...if given the opportunity...
...and I think our job is about helping other people escape that negative cycle.
I didn't think I would ever get to the other side...
...and now it seems like all my prayers and all my dreams, kind of being answered one by one.